[Music]
it's time for et social study your quick
look at what the stars are posting
online she always looked this good with
no makeup oh yeah better even better
without makeup
check out this throwback pic deck
shepard posted to instagram celebrating
the fact kristen bell eventually married
him
despite the nasty dip habit he had at
the time Amber Rose keeps flaunting her
romance with Dancing with the Stars Pro
Val Chmerkovskiy
another thing she's definitely not
hiding her fresh makeup tree face we are
thrilled were thrilled to see Candace
Cameron Bure rocking some new auburn
locks first on social media and again on
the red carpet
it's the Pepsi zero sugar Superbowl
halftime show
lady gaga is taking her Super Bowl
performance prep so seriously
she even built a giant rehearsal space
in her backyard so this is Jessica
beautiful Jessica Alba found out what it
feels like to have your face tattooed on
someone else's body so honored when it
comes to cute kids Jennifer Lopez's art
winning and winning and Max anemone are
getting so big there oh they're so big
and so amazing and happy Jude Law's 16
year old daughter iris has lots to be
happy about - she's officially the new
face of Burberry's I'm psyched rails
you